sometimes I put the bear on and pretend
that Jeremy's shouting at me is that a
guilty pleasure
Zach oh
jeez hi I'm Harris Dickson Zack Efron
Jeremy alen white We're the cast of
ironclaw and today we're going to be
playing with
[Music]
puppies bring them in bring in the house
oh wow we don't deserve
this look up
here oh my gosh how big are you going to
get oh this is not fair oh come on in
you can come up as well yes okay I knew
I liked puppies but I didn't know quite
how effective this would be in bringing
me Immediate Joy therapy this has just
solved years of trauma sweeth you feel
left out just
come yeah jump in oh man they're so
nervous they are just like me it's
okay ready for the first question so I
don't
[Music]
know I had never played a real person
before trying to find that balance of
doing um doing that person Justice and
trying to tell their story as honestly
as possible while not trying to mimic
them and like like make it your own
while at the same time doing Justice to
their to their story yeah there's like a
fine line that you are between trying to
get it perfect and also still kind of
having some of your own you know stuff
going on in the character and that's
that's hard especially when you know
they're going to see it you really want
to do them Justice now how do you guys
sitting with these the flip side of it
as well would be like there is so
much just lay down there is so much
material out there on on the brothers
and the family so I guess that's like a
sort of ease that you can access that
always
helps
oh jeez sorry I'm not listening
questions Sean always spoke about the
love of the brothers that was always a
big thing there is a great deal of
tragedy obviously in the story and it's
a true story but I think it was
important to highlight the drama and the
tragedy of the story while also yeah
celebrating the brother's relationship
the way that they kind of showed love
was in a competitive nature but it was
also really immense teamwork it was
pretty Next Level we got to bond pretty
quickly cuz as soon as we got to set we
were thrown into the end so to speak
with wrestling to be physical like that
straight away you kind of break down
social barriers very quickly in
underwear it's like it was a good crash
course into how to Bee Brothers I feel
like I might get peed on but I'm not mad
I'm not I'm not
[Music]
mad shocking shocking shocking
definitely can take myself seriously oh
what's wrong you don't like the Wiggy
either he thought it was okay when it
was all together and we all had our wigs
on and we were all in uh you know Cho
denim it looked great it looked like uh
we belong together together the Wardrobe
in the head that did like a lot of the
work for us in a weird way to just like
getting comfortable and confident in
that wardrobe and with the hair I was
like half the
[Music]
battle we were filming the whole time
there's a sequence in the movie when we
like have to sneak out of the house and
we all get to go to push the truck out
of our parents driveway that was funny
that was like ly's like first day new
energy and then we got to go to a house
party Stanley played a real song and
they played it live so as we entered the
party it was in one shot it was epic we
just got to walk into it really fun
house party and all the boys were there
drinking real beer drink real beer real
[Music]
beer so Mora never got the claw Mora
never got the claw I wouldn't
dare I'm obsessed with the bear is that
a guilty pleasure Act
it sometimes I put the bear on and
pretend that Jeremy's shouting at me you
know anytime anytime you need me I do
love reality reality is interesting
below deck below deck below deck there's
so many seasons over you can pop in at
any
time I think I would still like to do
this wrestling thing that we've spoken
about we want to wrestle in the WWE
together now we said it now we said it
we were like amped up on the last day
said like we should be in the WWE
people are doing that
PowerPoint puppies nothing nothing I
know nothing my head is empty I love of
these two yeah it's true a they as cute
as these
puppies my Northern side of my family do
egg rolling they throw eggs downhills
and they chase after them what is that
what say say again they they throw like
a boiled egg down a hill and they chase
it how do you win you don't win no
winers do you fall on the way some do
about you guys Christmas was a very big
deal in in my house my dad would go to
these crazy lengths to make sure that my
sister and I still believed in Santa
Claus you'd get soot all over our carpet
in the house and then you would have
like a fit in the morning like so angry
at Santa Claus he really went to some
lengths he would put sigh bells on the
rooftop and days later like point it out
so I believed in Santa Claus until near
years
ago these guys are falling as sleep we
put them to
sleep our wrestling coach sha Guerrero
he would tell us to like go home and
punch a pillow to like get the punches
right you were like I've been doing that
for years I've been doing that for a
long time you had so much to do man when
you're filming a movie for something
this cool and elevated with pro
wrestling it's very physical with that
kind of stuff on camera I've always felt
like the greater the sacrifice the
greater the reward but it' be hard to
sustain that I like eating real food too
much some bruises some soreness and
stuff like I didn't quite realize just
how little padding there was between the
kind of like Plywood And Springs the
ropes or like cable like metal cable
thin of foam yeah I was like we're
making a movie so we don't have to do it
the real way right yeah I just always
thought there was going to be some extra
layer of padding like the movie B we
throw an extra ST we're making movies
guys if anything we had like a vintage
ring we were using like older parts we
got to shoot a lot of whole matches all
the way through which as fun as that is
cinematically execution is another story
on like the 10th seven or eight minute
long take you're like yeah there's a lot
of bruising but we just kind of you just
you keep it together yeah nothing crazy
little blood couple missing teeth okay
all
right I think they're all coming to
sleep
here one of my favorite things to do is
bike around New York City where where
I'm from like cycle I don't wear a
helmet I really really should bit of an
adrenaline the wind in your head yeah
shark diving turn go south quickly if
you're not careful you got to be careful
with that that's better bit cooler being
on like in the ring was scary like the
resting in front of people I remember
being like why have I done this I felt
like an idiot the first time I jumped
off the top rope in front of the whole
crowd I was thinking to myself in that
moment how the hell did you end up
[Music]
here taxes taxes ah no one taught us put
it in the curriculum I want to be better
at cooking what do you like to cook I
could probably do like three things I
can make like a good omelette okay WR
yeah sandwich a sandwich I make don't
laugh that was some judgment
any I remember I missed a day at school
once and everyone told the school that I
was like had left school to go to some
like special program with like the
government and I came back and I was
like just was Ill I'm not related to
Jean Wilder I think a lot of people
think I am that's hilarious I've
addressed it before see it still thing
are you Jean W I am actually
[Music]
Jean Zach Zach would you absolutely my
mother's the only person who would pick
up a FaceTime call from me immediately
she's a celebrity to me I think Nicole
Nicole K just cuz we did it the other
day so that's FaceTime what
[Music]
about the truth is it's so reckless that
I've never given it any real thought
like this was the only option and if
this didn't work feel like I'd be in
real trouble I might like to do
something involves working with animals
puppies to be exact I enjoyed working on
a bar I could see myself doing that I'll
probably do some cowboy stuff out in the
woods that's a joke job yeah Cowboy
Cowboy's a job is it I could have done
that this whole
time it did a show called Shameless for
a long time and when that show ended I
like ran through the house and stole all
sorts of stuff from like the the the
room where my character grew up there
was something that like hung on the door
we called it like the killing bat it's
like this baseball bat and I stole that
had everybody sign it and actually our
showrunner called me and was like we
need that back um we're going to you
know like raffle it for charity and I
was like I already had everybody sign it
like I don't think you you want it back
now and he was kind of like all right
let's let's still have that I thought
about the boots those snakes skin boots
I didn't have the courage I didn't have
the courage to wear them in the real
world is Jeremy you look great thanks
man something about dancing with other
people that know how to do it a lot
better and you sort of just get to sit
and focus and learn in a mirror and it
teaches you about your physicality
wrestling for us kind of was dancing it
is like a Tango there's an aspect of
like with dance an understanding of your
body in space and I and I feel like
specifically for professional wrestling
it's it's so important to be able to
like gauge the amount of space you're
taking up your arms hurt that's the CEST
thing I've ever seen about all I was
worried I was worried you might had
locked them yeah then stopped
breathing definitely cook for the like
that didn't come naturally to me not
that the wrestling came like incredibly
naturally
but no come right
here oh this is amazing you cooked with
Dave Baron and I cooked yeah I cooked
with the Chef Dave who was really
helpful I think it took like a lot more
repetition in time I spent like 6 months
in in restaurants and culinary schooling
with Chef Dave and stuff like
that just give me some puppies I take
what I'm giving okay we had a lot of fun
in this movie I know it seems quite
serious but getting up there in the ring
we got after it man that's
true yeah I have a feature film I'm
making next year it's kind of drama with
some like satirical comedy also a young
man who ends up working in a hotel
kitchen so maybe oh really come and help
Jeremy yeah yeah
yeah haris is the best why me cuz you
are dude you dude you brought another
level to it I I think I have quite big
hands maybe maybe that's all I have
really going for myself go ahead
well I need a
head use the dog use the dog I remember
hul who plays Fritz really squeezed my
head do you remember the first time we
met yeah when we were wrestling in ring
and he put me in a headlock that was so
tight yeah yeah yeah I think to kind of
like to show this was like during
rehearsals like before we even started
shooting I remember making eye contact
with Harris just being like oh this is
where to
[Music]
go uh and a lot of people think that's
it's going to get me when they do it but
I was so prepared but it was very sweet
he has a great voice I felt very special
it's a classic mate C cult classic
Trilogy of films that rent free in my
head
sweet the rock me interesting me to play
you yeah oh yeah right yeah yeah yeah do
you have a doppelganger I think there's
a couple out there Aquaman's coming out
Jason M MOA just the man list
yeah I did Shameless for about 12 years
I started that show when I was 18 and
wrapped just after my 30th birthday so
saying goodbye to lip Gallagher that was
that was a big one I played a character
on a show that's out at the moment
called Mur at the end of the world and I
had a mullet for it at the end of it I
was like I guess this is just me now
felt like very comfortable with who had
become and then my mom was like you need
to cut that like
ASAP I think this one was pretty hard
for me to let go I did not know what it
was about it looked in the mirror they
took the you know wig off and the tan
kind of faded and I was like I just felt
like a different person it was it was a
lot we all still have a shot at pro
wrestling right I think so I think so so
we can run it back thanks thank you so
much BuzzFeed all these dogs are
adoptable from so adopt them Wags and
walks I might adopt them first
definitely watch ironclaw in theaters
December
22nd we don't deserve this I don't we
don't deserve this
[Music]
leave